[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Brian Cranston great
actor filmmaker Malcolm in the Middle
Breaking Bad Broadway he's done it all
whose uh Jersey are you retiring actor
and
actress
wow
um I actually Daniel de Lewis is a good
call but uh when he went off I thought
he was going to become peach cobbler
like down that that would be something
tasty he's good enough actor to actually
become peach cobbler you could actually
taste his work have you met Daniel de
Lewis I did I met
him uh we we met uh standing next to
each other in the bathroom at at the at
the urinals okay which is an interesting
place to meet someone because you don't
want to make eye contact you don't
you're not going to shake hands you just
kind of give each other a look and then
wait until your business is done and
then get out there and then you talk
outside what event were you at uh it was
the AFI Awards where um they they award
the 10 best television shows and the 10
best movies on any given year and he was
there for uh Phantom thread the the the
last film that he was doing that uh
phenomenal actor and a sweet guy a very
very sweet guy who stays in character
his entire run of the shoot so when he
was doing Lincoln all the other actors
would say good morning Mr President how
are you Mr President good morning and he
would stay in character all the time and
I thought that's interesting so he stays
in character as a character that was you
know 165 years ago or whatever um but so
he's at the craft service tables
Mr President your bagel just popped up
from the toaster it looks ready have you
could you have stayed in character with
either Hal with Malcolm in the Middle or
Walter White Breaking
Bad
no uh no why it well because it's too
too much energy you you need well just
like you know you you got to take your
breaks and so so do actors I mean you if
you try to sustain a level of energy all
the way through I I you would be I'd be
exhausted after the first three hours
and you wouldn't be able to perform then
you know you you got to have the breaks
well I would think with Breaking Bad it
was so serious and you know there's
there's a lot of bad things that happen
whereas on Malcolm in the Middle you've
got to be a kid the entire time if that
yeah right yeah yeah but it it still
takes a tremendous amount amount of
energy yeah I mean it's not like sitting
behind a microphone yeah yeah that's you
know you you use up mental energy yes I
do you got to burn the the oil that way
have you ever seen me in any of the
movies that I've been in
films I I've you were in
um Adam samler movie yeah um quite a few
of yeah 20 of them um you have you have
a a very easy touch you have a very you
do you you ease into those roles and you
it feels natural and that's the hardest
thing to do by the
way you were you're you're doing
something that is unnatural because
there's cameras around there's people
around you're saying specific things and
they say go do it right now and you have
to do it over and over and over again
and you have to see see As Natural as
possible and you do quite a good job
well they called me Daniel Day Patrick
when I was on set s just to to let you
know but I haven't done like a nude
scene or a sex scene you've you've been
involved in those that yeah how much
acting how much more acting is it when
let's say it's a serious scene where
somebody dies as opposed to you're
having a sex
scene well it's it's then more emotional
isn't it if you're doing if you're doing
something where
you're you're you know finding the
depths of pain or anguish that's that's
tremendously exhausting because again
you're doing it over and over again now
when when I was doing my when I do
Broadway it's even harder when you're on
stage because if a play is Well written
in every single part of that play you
have some kind of emotional content to
it so instead of one day oh I have an
emotional day on a movie when you do a
play it's every day you're you're every
single day you've got to muster up that
energy to go through that Gauntlet have
you met Merill Street oh
yeah and yeah she's but she's you know
what what I I got to say it in the 45
years that I've been working there's
probably it's probably three or four
people I really would not want to work
with again so I I really love my the the
people I work with and the the the
people I've met you know Daniel de Lewis
was sweet and unassuming and and kind
and rather
shy um Merill is funloving and she's got
a bright Spirit about her uh you know I
mean just just it it's just crazy um
there's a lot of people that that I I
cherish working with and and look
forward to
again my uh my youngest daughter says
that uh I remind her of Steve Martin in
how I and how I
look yeah there's a Steve Martin Essence
to you thank you yeah yeah there is is
that that's not the first time you've
heard it is it no I had a um an Uber
driver saying that he was surprised that
I took an Uber because and I go who do
you think I am and he goes are are you
playing me and I go no and he goes
you're in that murder in the building
thing and I go oh I'm not Steve Martin
he goes okay sure like sure you aren't
or something like that I go Noe I'm uh
I'm not him but he he didn't believe me
yeah yeah um by the way uh we were going
to have Brian on because things are a
little tough in Hollywood and he's
picking up a side gig as a bartender and
got hired by Drake and you were the U
guest bartender at a surprise party for
the uh legendary musician Entertainer
Drake how did that come about well uh a
friend of ours a restaurant tour Named
Dave grutman um who owns a bunch of
restaurants down in throughout the
country uh he said are you guys
available Monday and we we really
weren't we we had to cancel a couple
things around we said why he says
because uh one of my restaurants we're
going to have um we're gonna have Drake
and his whole party it's very intimate
party and it would be fun if you guys
came over and you know bartended and
made do ombr me mcal cocktails and for
for Drake and his friends and it's like
yeah I think we got to do that I think
we got to do that so we kind of shifted
things around we flew into Miami this
was just last Monday and uh it you it's
a it was a fun night it was a fun night
we're making we're making the grones and
oldfashioned mcal and and it was fun to
see him and what a sweet guy talk talk
about a different Persona on stage as
off and I I always look for that and I
always respect and admire when I see
someone who has is able to allow
themselves to be seen in a in a calm not
performance mode kind of way and Drake
was just really a cool dude you know
really fun how was the
house well it wasn't I mean how many
people or do you mean that the venue
itself venue it was a restaurant it was
it was one of the the Dave grutman's
restaurants and they just it open
beautiful uh and who were the other
celebrities there oh God I knew you were
going to ask me that I was busy working
you know someone's got to just get their
heads down and put the ice in the well
so you did not know the other people
there is what you're saying no I'm not
I'm not good at that you know you know
we're about the same age and it's like I
knew Drake and I you know I know some of
his songs you know and one of one of the
we were singing is like uh one of the
lyrics of the song goes like um uh I I
live I live for the nights I won't
remember with with the people that I
won't forget you know and it's like it
it was it was it's cool and um so it's
it was a lot of fun we we
danced uh there was there was a lot good
food and it was just and really chilled
because it wasn't overcrowded it was
very private um it was just his invited
guest but he knew who you were like when
he saw okay yeah he he he's a a big
Breaking Bad fan so it was it was fun to
and he didn't know we were coming so we
were behind the bar serving drinks and
someone guided him up to the bar and and
uh we just you know what can I get you
sir and he went
out but but you're there you're there
with Aaron Paul who was Jesse Pinkman so
uh you you two travel I hear you guys
are uh cleaning Snoop dogs pool this
weekend too so you guys can be hired out
which is pretty awesome when are you
getting back to work by the
way yeah we um we're we're hoping
um we're we're very happy that the uh
the the Studios have agreed to sit down
with us again to talk with our
negotiating committee um and they're
doing a terrific job it's very difficult
the conversation is is not easy to have
it's been over a 100 days now but we
need to to maintain that strength and
unity because what we're trying to
accomplish is a living wage for the
working actor and as of right now that
is not happening because of the the
streaming um platforms have have
diminished an actor's ability to to make
a living yeah it really has there were
revenue streams that were available to
an actor before and you needed all of
them collectively to be able to just
make a living and that has all dwindled
away so we have to get it back to secure
an actor's ability to make a fine and
decent living great to talk to you as
always and uh hopefully this gets
settled here soon and we're hoping yeah
and good luck with the the mcow thanks
DP thank you buddy that's Brian Cranston
actor filmmaker Breaking Bad Malcolm in
the Middle and uh as uh dos ombres mcow
that he sent to us very tasty